madame monsieur bonjour et très heureux
de vous accueillir en direct sur le
plateau de la voix et libre en Bourgogne
aujourd'hui nous poursuivons notre série
consacrée au maire des grandes villes de
la région à la proche des municipales de
mars 2014 et c'est le sénateur maire de
la capitale régionale qui est avec nous
ce samedi bonjour Françoise samen
bonjour alors chacun devant sa télé peut
vous poser des questions ou réagir via
notre site internet bourgogne.france
3.fr notre page Facebook ou bien sûr sur
Twitter hashtag F3 Bourgogne Françoise
on va résumer votre parcours en quelques
dates 1951 c'est la date de votre
naissance à Dijon
en 80 au lendemain de l'élection de
François Mitterrand vous adhérez au PS
après avoir été membre de la LCR en 89
vous présentez pour la première fois à
la mairie de Dijon vous échouez mais
vous devenez le premier opposant à
Robert Poujade en 95 vous devenez
conseiller régional puis 90 en 98
conseillers général c'est votre première
victoire personnelle en 2001 vous êtes
élu maire de Dijon réélu en 2008 date à
laquelle vous êtes également élu
sénateur vous êtes aujourd'hui le
président du groupe socialiste au Sénat
c'est avec cette étiquette là qu'on va
commencer cette émission quelques
minutes pour parler des grands dossiers
nationaux quand vous avez eu
connaissance des chiffres du chômage
cette semaine qu'est-ce que vous êtes
dit ouf en une bonne nouvelle oui je me
suis dit promesse tenue parce que on a
beaucoup brocardé le président de la
République quand il avait dit qu'il
arriverait à faire la version de la
courbe du chômage avant la fin de
l'année vous êtes sûr que ça va durer
enfin c'est déjà une première bonne
nouvelle et ça me permet de dire qu'elle
est amplifiée en Côte-d'Or c'est à dire
que le chômage en Côte-d'Or a reculé de
9% au mois de
8,8,8 vous avez tout à fait raison et
donc près de 9% et sur un an il a reculé
ce qui est ce qui est plus important
légèrement c'est vrai 0,2 % mais il a
reculé en un an et notamment le chômage
des jeunes c'est très important donc
c'est une bonne nouvelle ah maintenant
il faut il faut être modeste quand même
c'est une bonne nouvelle on la prend une
bonne nouvelle il y en a pas beaucoup en
ce moment au niveau de l'activité on en
attend une bonne sur l'activité
économique du trimestre qui je pense va
être supérieur à ce qu'on attendait mais
pour autant il faut continuer il faut
continuer et ça ne sera perceptible par
les gens parce que le chômage on en
parle comme ça par des statistiques mais
en réalité c'est ici c'est dijonnais des
Français des françaises qui sont dans la
difficulté et donc ça ne sera
perceptible que quand ça s'amplifiera au
cours de l'année 2014 c'est mon souhait
le plus cher et c'est surtout la
politique est menée à ça comme but
l'emploi l'emploi l'emploi l'autre
grande dossier actuel c'est la fiscalité
on a annoncé une réforme de la fiscalité
malgré tout ce week-end vous avez vu il
y a de nombreuses manifestations alors
les bonnets rouges en Bretagne les
routiers enfin certains routiers de de
l'autre
puis le Front de Gauche aussi demain et
un mouvement qui s'appelle stop Hollande
alors est-ce que c'est légitime de
finalement de manifester contre la
hausse de la fiscalité selon vous
François abdsamen les dégustation c'est
pas moi qui vais dire que c'est pas
légitime on a le droit de manifester
dans ce pays donc elles sont de nature
différente mais elles ont un caractère
un peu corporatiste pour la plupart
d'entre elles c'est du plus jeune j'ai
dit un peu corporatiste j'irai peut-être
pas jusqu'à poujadiste mais par certains
mouvements où on peut on peut se
rapprocher et si vous voulez Nicolas
Sarkozy il avait mis 3 millions de
personnes dans la rue pas trois millions
de personnes dans la rue aujourd'hui
heureusement d'ailleurs donc cette
répondre aux demandes mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a une pression fiscale qui a
atteint une limite et donc il y aura en
2014 une stabilisation et en 2015 une
baisse des prélèvements obligatoires
c'est un engagement qui a été pris par
le Président de la République comme
celui sur la courbe du chômage et donc
ça sera tenu pour ça il faut faire des
économies il faut faire des économies
vous parlez de François Hollande après
on va s'intéresser à Dijon à vous parler
de François Hollande il a l'image d'un
homme qui recule qui est un peu hésitant
à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur on le
sent assez ferme sur plusieurs dossiers
en Afrique sur la Syrie comment vous
expliquer vous cette dichotomie et cette
perception en tout cas en France d'un
président un peu mou qui hésite qui ne
sait pas trop où il va il y a un vrai
décalage entre l'image de François
Hollande au niveau international pas
qu'en France il est estimé imprécier
écouter au niveau européen et au niveau
international respecter et au niveau
national c'est plus compliqué parce que
il y a d'autres intervenants il y a bien
bien sûr des contre-pouvoirs il y a le
Parlement et puis il y a les forces
sociales et donc et puis il y a sa
volonté d'apaiser la société de remettre
du dialogue de faire un peu l'inverse de
ce que faisait Nicolas Sarkozy ça ça
prend du temps et je pense qu'il va y
arriver il est pas du tout c'est pas du
tout quelqu'un qui hésite à prendre des
décisions je suis pas je cherche une
image pour moi François Hollande c'est
un galet il est il est dur à l'intérieur
beaucoup plus qu'on ne le croit beaucoup
plus que il peut même être cassant
presque aut certaines fois presque
autoritaires certaines fois donc c'est
une image tout à fait contraire je parle
de son caractère mais en même temps il a
cette volonté d'écoute d'apaisement et
de trouver la voie qui permette à tout
le monde de la voie du compromis et je
pense c'est une bonne chose à
réhabiliter le compromis dans notre pays
donc vous pariez toujours sur sa réalité
j'en suis pas là mais je vous ai entendu
le dire oui mais il y a 3 ans on a 3 ans
et demi il faut surtout que la droite se
fasse à l'idée que on a encore 3 ans et
demi et que c'est au bout de 5 ans qu'on
jugera la politique de François Hollande
trois ans à la tête dépend que du
président de la République que de lui en
tout cas vous feriez un très bon
ministre me dit quelqu'un là à l'instant
sur sur Internet c'est sympathique j'ai
refusé j'ai refusé d'être ministre parce
que j'ai choisi Dijon on va
énergistrement alors Dijon vous êtes
toujours candidat pour un troisième
mandat ce sera le dernier oui ce sera le
dernier si vous êtes élu vous serez bien
jusqu'au bout donc jusqu'en 2020 parce
que tout le monde se pose une question
je vais vous poser celle de Robert sur
Internet monsieur epsamen si vous êtes
élu maire de Dijon en mars 2014 et peu
de temps après on vous propose de
devenir ministre de l'Intérieur quel
sera votre décision non mais j'attends
déjà qu'on me propose d'être mes
intérieurs on vous la propriété et puis
non on m'a jamais proposé cette musique
d'intérieur et on m'a proposé d'autres
postes mais pas celui-là et puis moi je
suis respectueux des échéances je suis
candidat à être maire de Dijon à nouveau
et donc je vais respecter les échéances
je force sympathique la personne qui qui
vous demande ça mais déjà il faut être
élu et il faut pas brûler les étapes et
donc faut être respectueux du suffrage
universel et puis ensuite je prends
l'engagement d'être ministre jusqu'en
2020 ça c'est ce que rêve ou ce que
pense certains en réalité on sait pas ce
qui va se passer je prends l'engagement
moi d'assumer mon mandat de maire
jusqu'en 2020
vous êtes candidat aussi au sénatorial
l'an prochain
je serai éventuellement candidat au
sénatorial je sais pas on verra oui a
priori vous avez entendu François
Patriat cette semaine le président de
région qui lance sa propre liste contre
on imagine la vôtre oui c'est le divorce
non entre deux amis de 30 ans
amicales avec avec François Patriat il y
a un peu de l'eau dans le gaz si on
exprimer ainsi bon on verra on verra il
faut il faut prendre les échéances les
unes après les autres non c'est ce qui
m'a juste fait sourire c'est le terme à
une candidature défensive je connaissais
beaucoup de termes de candidatures
candidature de gauche une candidature de
rassemblement de la candidature
défensive ça je connaissais pas mais moi
je dis ça avec humour allez venons à
votre bilan à la tête de l'Amérique
Dijon alors qu'on la prouve non c'est va
la ville a beaucoup changé depuis votre
arrivée en quelques mots est-ce que vous
êtes fier de ce que vous avez fait
jusqu'à présent et est-ce que vous
reconnaissez des erreurs aussi oui je
d'abord je ne suis pas le seul à avoir
agi c'est moi et mon équipe donc son
équipe aussi municipale j'ai des
adjoints de grande qualité oui oui je
suis relativement heureux de ce que on a
fait pour améliorer la vie des habitants
pour permettre à cette ville de
retrouver une attractivité qu'elle était
en train de perdre pour cette développer
pour être rayonnante pour être d'où ça
vibre oui j'en suis j'en suis fier mais
les déjeuners sont fiers ils sont
d'abord c'est leur slogan vous le savez
ils sont fiers d'être dijonnais et donc
je crois qu'il y a une fierté de cette
ville et ça c'est c'est quelque chose de
formidable d'être fier de sa ville de la
trouver belle de l'affaire visiter de la
montrer il suffit de voir les déjeuners
quand ils reçoivent des habitants
d'autres villes des touristes comment
ils montrent leur vie ils ont ils ont
une fierté de la ville et ça ça aide à
mer ça aide à mer ça m'a aidé ça m'a
aidé beaucoup le changement le plus
visible de ce deuxième mandat ça aurait
été bien sûr le l'arrivée du tramway le
calendrier a été parfaitement maîtrisé à
tout le monde a oublié un peu les
galères des travaux
mais il y a toujours d'autres critiques
comme l'asphyxie organisée pour les
automobilistes distillent je vous
propose d'écouter à ce sujet l'un des
candidats à votre succession il s'agit
du sénateur UMP Alain louper on y
revient après Dijon est thrombosé et
quand
un tissu est thrombosé en médecine il se
décrose donc Dijon est embolisé
bouchonné et il est important de de
restaurer les flux je pense que François
aime ça mène ne répondra que si il y a
des bouchons c'est parce qu'il y a des
activités moi je réponds que c'est parce
qu'on a diminué les flux on a rétrécié
les flux il est important pour qu'il y
ait de la vie que les flux les plus
grandissent les flux la vie c'est des
flux c'est des flux d'habitants c'est
des flux c'est des flux de liens c'est
du lien entre les habitants il faut que
les gens puissent se déplacer d'un
endroit à l'autre quel que soit les
moyens à pied à vélo en voiture en bus
en tramway est important de faciliter
les transports pour que les gens se
mettent en lien et c'est ça qui est
important et je souhaite
qu'il me donne une réponse si c'est flux
si c'est liens le lui correspondent s'il
se reconnaît dans cette diminution des
alors en clair Alain houpère estime que
le tramway a amené plus de difficultés
de circulation à Dijon ça vous l'assumer
vous avez traduit sa question parce que
j'avouerai que je n'ai pas bien compris
merci merci parce que sinon j'aurais pas
su quoi vous répondre
j'inviterai
le candidat UMP le maire de salive je
l'inviterai à regarder des photos de ce
qui était la thrombose avant 2001 j'ai
des photos formidables de la place
d'Arcy avec comment dit-il des flux avec
des flux bloqués mais c'était 4 voix
bloquées huit voies bloquées donc
je voudrais ajouter quand on est
candidat il faut être il faut aimer la
ville dans laquelle on est candidat il
faut arrêter la dénigrer il faut il faut
l'aimer il faut l'apporter Dijon à une
belle ville et il faut aimer sa ville il
a peut-être son village mais il faut
aimer sa vie il faut arrêter de
critiquer on peut pas être élu si on
critique
une ville on arrive dans une ville
surtout qu'une ville comme Dijon c'est
aussi belle qu'elle est avec des
habitants qui sont quand on dit vivre
vous pensez on a d'autres questions sur
internet sur le même sujet notamment
Christophe à l'instant vous pensez que
la circulation ça se déroule comme vous
l'aviez imaginé avec l'arrivée du
tramway mais écoutez franchement
l'activité économique elle est à Dijon
les les habitants beaucoup d'habitants
viennent travailler à Dijon 40% des
emplois je crois sur toute la région
donc que ça soit la vallée de louche la
plaine de la Saône ils viennent en
voiture donc on a essayé et on fait des
parkings relais il y a des trams il y a
des gens qui viennent en voiture
aujourd'hui il y a pas la lino on va
avoir réussi la lino c'était quand même
mais oui elle va être ouverte le
problème c'est qu'elle devait être
ouverte en même temps que le tram or
elle a pris du retard elle ou peut-être
le tram a-t-il été vite vous avez vu que
les experts de Rio de Janeiro sont venus
voir comment on a réussi le tram c'est
formidable pour une ville comme Dijon de
pouvoir rencontrer comme ça et donc
j'avoue que je comprends pas bien la
rhétorique du candidat UMP avant de de
reparler de la lino là dont vous que
vous venez d'évoquer deux questions
notamment une sur Facebook et sur
internet par rapport à Divia puisqu'on
parlait du tramway il y a ce conflit qui
dure depuis des semaines et des semaines
le samedi qui devient maintenant un peu
populaire nous dit Dany 21 89 est-ce que
vous pensez intervenir dans ce conflit
je suis intervenu oui c'est un populaire
oui c'est vrai c'est pas c'est pas
acceptable je le dis aux salariés qui
qui font grève vous savez il y a eu un
accord d'entreprise il a été signé par
une organisation syndicale la CFDT c'est
une augmentation de salaire et une prime
qui a été votée la CGT est faux de Divia
avait trois jours pour dénoncer cet
accord ils ne l'ont pas dénoncé ils
avaient la possibilité de le dénoncer le
lendemain ils ont déposé un préavis de
grève d'un an pour le samedi donc moi
j'ai demandé à la direction ça va se
passer lundi de faire des nouvelles
propositions de rouvrir le dialogue avec
les de la CGT de FO qui sont en grève
alors c'est pas une grève totale on va
dire c'est une glace perlée elle touche
surtout les bus de la périphérie mais
c'est très gênant pour les habitants et
c'est très gênant pour moi donc j'ai
demandé à la direction de rouvrir les
négociations on aura une réponse lundi
donc après on prendra des décisions en
fonction de la réponse qui sera donnée
j'espère que j'espère vraiment que les
salariés qui sont bien traités qui sont
bien traités à Divia qui ont des
salaires parmi les plus élevés de France
de Keolis qui sont respectées pour
lesquelles il y a du dialogue social
j'espère vraiment qu'ils vont entendre
la proposition lundi la lino donc cette
fameuse c'est la suite en gros de la
rocade Est qui valait jusqu'à
l'autoroute A38 alors elle va ouvrir
quand alors les élections municipales
non on m'a dit avant c'est pas ça c'est
l'État qui pilote et donc je pense
qu'elle sera ouverte début février
d'après ce qu'on m'a dit je crois qu'il
y a une période de ce qu'on appelle un
essai à blanc parce qu'il y a un tunnel
enfin elle est terminée elle va être
terminée dans un mois un mois et demi et
donc
elle va désengorger aussi le
centre-ville toutes ces voitures de
transit qui n'ont pas à passer par le
centre-ville ou qui prennent le
boulevard périphérique qu'on appelle
boulevard périphérique et qui est devenu
un allé centrale quasiment une autoroute
urbaine donc ça va se décaler sur et
donc ça va faciliter la circulation et
sûrement comme on dit-il les flux allez
à ce propos je vous propose d'écouter un
habitant de Dijon qui a beaucoup
d'humour vous allez le voir il est
rencontré cette semaine par Arnaud
Lefèvre et Daniel vaccin
c'est pas mal la lino ça sera pas mal ça
va dégorger tout
Plombières tout des aussi
bon là c'est pas mal mais c'est dommage
qu'ils ont foutu ce radar tronçon sur la
lune je serai le maire je mets pas de
radar c'est la lino ça c'est clair et
net oui mais il y en a partout on fait
100 mètres
alors faut pas exagérer
alors Françoise vous êtes le responsable
de la mise en place de ce radar
je sais pas de me décharger de Me
responsabilité comme journée directement
c'est l'État qui assure la sécurité
routière c'est pas le maire de Dijon et
ni le président de l'agglomération mais
j'ai demandé à ce que la vitesse soit
limitée j'ai demandé à ce que ça soit
pas à 110 km/h et qu'on est une vitesse
limitée moi je serais même pour aller à
70 km/h je crois que ça va finalement
être 90 km/h sur cette portion là et
donc voilà alors est-ce que c'est
dangereux oui de toute façon la vitesse
trop de vitesse moi je suis pas pour des
limitations excessives mais sur cette
rocade des fois c'est dangereux oui à
110 km/h je trouve rapidement pour finir
sur les infrastructures
François Sauvadet a annoncé qu'il allait
arrêter de financer l'aéroport il y aura
bientôt plus d'avions militaires en tant
que merde de Dijon est-ce que vous
souhaitez toujours maintenir un aéroport
à Dijon est-ce que c'est vraiment la
peine écoutez vous savez que la région
puisque c'est elle qui est pilote dans
la matière a lancé une délégation de
service public moi je pense que
j'attends le résultat de de cette
délégation de service public pour voir
les réponses qui seront faites pour voir
le coût par rapport au service rendu moi
je souhaite que Dijon soit relié avec
quelques grandes villes françaises où la
liaison ferroviaire n'est pas suffisante
je pense à Toulouse je pense à Bordeaux
éventuellement à Nice et puis je
souhaite qu'on maintienne l'aviation
d'affaires qui est très importante et
qui rapporte beaucoup d'argent et donc
on verra en fonction mais ça sera à
débat en fonction de des réponses qui
seront faites s'il y a des réponses la
décision qu'on pourra prendre au premier
juin 2014 puisque il y a une convention
jusqu'au 1er juin 2014 alors il y a
beaucoup de grandes ces derniers temps
chez les commerçants en tout cas chez
certains dans eux il y a de l'inquiétude
pour la vitalité du centre-ville écouter
les réflexions et questionnements de ces
jeunes au niveau de la Toison d'or c'est
très beau
par contre j'ai bien peur que le
centre-ville empathie ça parce que moi
personnellement je travaille aux
Galeries Lafayette et je peux vous dire
qu'en ce moment les clients de se
battent pas je suis originaire de Dijon
j'ai fait une petite passage à
Strasbourg et c'est vrai que Strasbourg
est vraiment très piéton très en avance
là-dessus et c'est vrai que étant
commerçant en centre-ville je pense que
plus de rupton c'est plus plus sympa
comme ville donc en plus de rue piétonne
bon alors plusieurs questions
la Toison d'Or d'abord on va voir les
images impressionnantes de la foule lors
de l'inauguration de l'extension est-ce
que ça va être fatale au centre-ville
c'est ce que craignent les commerçants
non pas tous d'abord pas tous pas tous
il y en a qui qui font de très bonnes
affaires qui tant mieux pour eux qui
travaillent très bien et la
piétonnisation apporte beaucoup de monde
au centre-ville je conseille par exemple
d'aller voir cet après-midi et en plus
il y a les illuminations le centre-ville
c'est c'est essentiel c'est
indispensable alors après il y a aussi
je m'excuse ils aiment pas quand je dis
ça les commerçants mais il y a aussi la
qualité des commerces et puis il y a
aussi la qualité de l'accueil et puis il
y a aussi les heures d'ouverture il y a
encore des commerçants qui sont fermés
entre midi et deux heures donc depuis
des années
à dire la CCI le dit et puis il sortait
dans une association qui s'appelle
shopping Dijon qui fonctionne très bien
sous l'impulsion de mon adjointe
Nathalie kunders et il travaille
ensemble on fait des animations au
centre-ville il y a beaucoup de monde au
centre-ville après les problèmes de
pouvoir d'achat mais le centre-ville il
va pas il va pas périr c'est le premier
pôle d'emploi de l'agglomération c'est
une chance formidable c'est c'est une
belle ville il y a des touristes le
musée des Beaux-Arts ramène du monde il
y a eu 100 000 visiteurs on pourra dire
à la fin de l'année entre septembre et
la fin de l'année donc voilà non c'est
une vraie chance alors après je connais
des commerçants qui qui font des
chiffres d'affaires tant mieux pour eux
absolument
colos formidable
vous parliez la rue des comment la
piétonnisation chinois a pu apporter de
l'activité voilà donc on va continuer à
gérer tout ça la Toison d'Or elle a
cette capacité d'attirer très loin de
l'Alsace même me disait-on donc
répercussions aussi sur le reste après
c'est aussi au commerçants du
centre-ville à travers shopping Dijon
d'attirer ceux qui vont à la Toison d'Or
et qui viennent en voiture pour qu'ils
prennent le train le tram pour venir au
centre-ville et donc il y a un
aller-retour mais bien sûr que ça va
profiter au centre-ville aussi vous
parlez de l'association shopping Dijon
il y en a une deuxième qui s'est créée
cœur de ville avec sa tête Monsieur
Nicolas Vérel votre adjointe justement
Nathalie canders a dit que c'était une
association politique vous faites la
même analyse oh j'ai juste remarqué que
c'était l'assistant du groupe UMP à la
région mais bon après tout
qui est plein d'associations qui veulent
le développement de Dijon c'est très
bien surtout quand c'est des vraies
associations
Silvère pensez-vous que les petits
commerçant placés sur le parcours du
tramway vont voter pour la personne qui
a fait augmenter leur taxe terrasses de
300% est-ce qu'ils vont voter pour
augmentation de taxes de 300% c'est
définitivement résolu ce problème de
taxe avec l'Union des commerçants des
industries
des cafés des hôteliers avec lui ça se
passe ça se passe bien ça se passe bien
vous savez on a baissé contrairement à
ce qui se dit on a baissé la taxe dans
les quartiers et on l'a augmenté dans le
centre-ville dans liberscentre place de
la Libération je connais pas un
commerçant qui se plaignent des
terrasses ni de du tarif qui paye
le logement ça s'était aussi un grand
axe de votre de votre politique avec le
PLU qui avait été signé en 2010 si je me
souviens bien c'était quoi c'était mille
logements par an on parle de bétonnage
face à certains parlent de bétonnage ou
bétonnez la ville
à cet instant j'ai préféré être avec
vous que d'inaugurer donc c'est mes
adjoints qui le font le jardin de
l'Arsenal c'est 5000 m² de jardin donc
on a créé beaucoup de jardins je ferai
le le bilan le moment venu on a créé des
espaces verts Dijon est une ville où il
y a beaucoup d'espaces verts et donc
ceux qui parlent de bétonnage sont
souvent ceux qui vendent leurs propres
maisons pour permettre la construction
de logements et même des UMP qui font ça
vous voyez même des des élus MP donc
c'est le travail des journalistes de
voir qui c'est une quinzaine de
d'écosiers 14 15 je n'ai plus le chiffre
en tête excusez-moi mais c'est que c'est
quoi votre le but vraiment c'était de
faire baisser le prix de l'immobilier
parce qu'il est quand même assez élevé
encore
il est encore trop élevé parce que il y
a quand même un équilibre de l'offre et
de la demande on a encore près du 8000
demandes de logement non satisfaits il y
a sûrement des doubles comptes dedans ça
veut pas dire que ce sont des gens qui
sont à la rue des gens qui veulent
changer il faut du mouvement de la
mobilité dans une ville et donc on
construit des logements mais il y a
tellement de retards quand on aura
construit suffisamment de logements et
bien les prix baisseront et on fait
attention à ce que la production
aujourd'hui correspondent aux capacités
on développe beaucoup l'accession
sociale au logement je le dis aux jeunes
couples par exemple avec la possibilité
c'est un nouveau produit qu'on va mettre
en place avec la possibilité en payant
15 ans de loyer d'être propriétaire au
bout de ces 15 ans donc il faut
favoriser toutes les le ce qu'on appelle
le parcours résidentiel le logement
locatif à loyer modéré l'accession
sociale à la propriété et puis
l'accession libre celle là cette fois
certaines fois c'est vrai qu'elle est
très élevée trop élevée le but c'était
aussi de d'atteindre les 160 000
habitants en 2020 c'est vraiment un but
et nous importe quoi finalement d'avoir
plus d'habitants ça permet d'ouvrir des
écoles vous savez il y a une espèce de
cercle vertueux
on m'avait dit que la population
baisserait sous mes mandat non elle a
augmenté mais elle augmente de manière
raisonnable donc il y a plus de jeunes
il y a plus d'activité relativement
stable quand même on est à 150
ça va continuer à monter progressivement
on ouvre des écoles il y a plus
d'activités économiques ça fait marcher
le commerce quand il y a de moins sur
moi de monde ça dépérissent et un cercle
vicieux nous on préfère le cercle
vertueux alors vous avez décidé aussi de
comment dirais-je d'intégrer la campagne
à la ville en rachetant un domaine là le
domaine de l'ACRA qui est à cheval sur
les communes de Dijon Plombières et
corcelles-lès-monts 160 hectares pas de
rentabilité voulue là c'est un million
trois c'est quoi vraiment la la
philosophie du projet je veux préserver
ce poumon vert de l'agglomération et de
la ville de Dijon ça prendrait 3 minutes
quand le chat a fait son lac parce qu'il
reste ça le lac du chanoine et bravo
chanoine quand le chanoine qui a fait
son lac il y a trois quartiers qui
devait être créés la fontaine de douche
il s'est créée le belvédère à talent il
s'est créé et le plateau de la craie et
le plateau de la craie et mon
prédécesseur Robert Poujade me disait
souvent ça sera le dernier espace à
l'urbaniser de la ville de Lyon mais moi
je ne le souhaite pas je ne souhaite pas
qu'on urbanie cet espace je souhaite
montrer que la ville est préserve aussi
le terrain agricole vous savez il faut
plutôt recoudre la ville sur elle-même
faire comment on fait avenue du drapeau
les gens peuvent le voir construire dans
les dents creuses qu'on appelle dans les
dents creuses c'est-à-dire dans les
petits espaces faire des logements
agréables plutôt que de s'étaler parce
qu'on doit préserver les terres
agricoles et là on les préserve et on
permet même à un domaine viticole de
s'étendre et puis on va travailler avec
la Chambre d'Agriculture et puis ça me
permet de montrer à ceux qui critiquent
toujours la ville que la ville elle est
aussi protectrice des terres agricoles
donc un domaine viticole qui va
s'agrandir ça permettra d'avoir 2000
bouteilles par an en plus pour le Grand
Dijon 2000 bouteilles ça servira à
accueillir nos invités et sûrement à
servir du blanc cassis allez avant la
pause on va commencer à parler
d'économie avec pour commencer une
remarque et une question d'un autre
candidat Édouard Cavin qui sera la tête
de liste du Front national à Dijon
monsieur Epson en tant que responsable
politique sur le plan local comme sur le
plan national vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que votre politique nationale
impacte de façon dramatique la situation
d'ygénèse en votant des lois qui sans
arrêt augmente les taxes etc que
comptez-vous faire pour l'économie d'y
Genèse
on fait on fait beaucoup de choses pour
l'économie dijonnaise d'ailleurs les
entrepreneurs à Dijon les chefs
d'entreprise sont satisfaits du
dynamisme de la ville bien sûr tout
n'est pas parfait bien sûr la crise
européenne la commande publique a été
très importante aussi pour soutenir la
qui permet de passer les moments les
plus difficiles je peux vous assurer que
tous les déjeuners le voient il suffit
de se promener dans la ville pour voir
tous les chantiers qui sont aujourd'hui
ouvert les entreprises du bâtiment des
travaux publics les secteurs des
services tout ça fait l'activité alors
on la soutient le plus possible ça va
continuer bien sûr ça va continuer il
faut continuer parce que c'est de
l'emploi derrière c'est toujours
l'emploi qui est la clé de tout cela et
puis on travaille pour implanter de
nouvelles entreprises et ceux qui disent
qu'il y a pas de création d'entreprise
sur des gens ne connaissent pas la
réalité économique alors maintenant
c'est plus des grandes unités comme
avant mais j'étais l'autre jour chez
jtec
sur l'agglomération Chevigny on voit
bien combien moi je m'intéresse à
l'activité économique je rencontre les
chefs d'entreprise je les pousse à
investir
Urgo qui se développe plasto qui fait
une nouvelle chaîne de montage donc on a
des secteurs qui fonctionnent très bien
le patron de la chocolaterie de
Bourgogne qui relance une activité voilà
alors il y a aussi des problèmes
industriels hier il y avait par cœur
alors justement par coeur vous avez
assisté à participer à la table ronde
d'hier j'avais demandé au préfet de
l'organisme tous les téléspectateurs on
peut rappeler qu'il y a 80 emplois qui
serait supprimés puisqu'il y a une
délocalisation partielle en Pologne ça
sert à quoi ce genre de table ronde
sinon à donner de l'espoir aux salariés
est-ce que c'est vraiment il peut en
ressortir quelque chose ah je crois
qu'hier il en est ressorti quelque chose
d'abord ça montre aux salariés auquel il
faut penser d'abord que on se préoccupe
de leur sort de leur avenir mais avant
de discuter du plan social d'entreprise
parce que le plan social de l'entreprise
c'est solution soit de
réindustrialisation soit de départ en
licenciement économique avec un montant
à discuter mais avant on a voulu dire
prouver au directeur des ressources
humaines de Parker que son plan était
faux mauvais et moi je lui ai dit ce que
je pensais il faut qu'il revoit sa copie
et la copine n'est pas juste et j'ai été
soutenu énormément ils connaissent le
dossier mieux que moi et mieux que tout
le monde par les organisations
syndicales non la responsabilité
étonnante dans cette affaire parce que
voilà on demande vous rendez compte
qu'on demande quasiment à des salariés
d'aller former ceux qui vont les
remplacer en République tchèque ou en
Pologne si c'est le cas de TRW c'est
incroyable c'est de la provocation c'est
c'est patron sont en réalité que des
financiers ils pensent qu'à faire monter
la bourse donc il faut vraiment se
battre avec les salariés encore du poids
sans leur donner de faux espoirs mais là
il y a un vrai espoir en tous les cas de
montrer au patron qui se plante il se
plante de projet économiques et qui font
des erreurs très graves et vous allez
encore du poids vous essayez en tout cas
oui je crois je crois je crois mais on
renverse pas comme ça d'un coup de
baguette magique je fais pas croire aux
salariés que je peux tout je peux pas
grand-chose je peux les soutenir les
aider et les accompagner allez on
s'interrompt quelques minutes pour le
flash régional de la mi-journée on se
retrouve dans cinq minutes donc place à
Elsa besoins à tout de suite